[Musique]
étranger
voir
[Musique]
alors, enfant, vous passiez vos
étés dans les montagnes de monash, alors quels
souvenirs avez-vous de cette époque ouais
mon grand-père était un cheval lager et  alors
euh nous devons faire partie de cette
exploitation forestière familiale vraiment et donc
mon arrière-grand-père mon grand-père tous
mes oncles
étaient tous des bûcherons de chevaux euh et nous avons dû faire une
sorte de sentier et
voir le tout
donc c'était assez excitant et il  était tout ce que nous
savions, donc nous ne connaissions que le buisson, nous
l'appelions le buisson,
donc votre grand-père était un bûcheron de chevaux,
comment l'industrie forestière a-t-elle
changé depuis le moment où il faisait du vlog
ouais, ça a radicalement changé alors
imaginez comme quand vous travaillez avec des
chevaux
et et  vraiment ces arbres sont énormes,
vous savez que ce sont des arbres anciens
, donc ils mesurent un mètre ou deux de
diamètre et pour couper un vieil arbre
comme ça
avec la scie à tronçonner ou même les premières
tronçonneuses, il faudrait un  jour ou deux pour
abattre un arbre  d donc
ils n'ont pas abattu beaucoup d'arbres en
été et c'était ce que nous appelons l'
exploitation forestière sélective afin qu'ils ne prennent
que ceux qu'ils pouvaient qu'ils pouvaient vendre
souvent c'étaient les arbres du sous-étage les
poteaux de cèdre euh pour faire des
poteaux téléphoniques  à cette époque,
l'exploitation forestière industrielle, d'autre part,
lorsque je suis devenu forestier, est
radicalement différente, c'est là que
vous le prenez, ils prennent tout et
lorsque ces plans ont été élaborés, c'était
avant le changement climatique, c'était avant que
quiconque ne s'inquiète de la biodiversité
et j'ai donc commencé à tirer  eux et j'ai
remarqué que vous connaissez cette différence dans
les systèmes racinaires de ces deux
débuts de vie radicalement différents
où ceux qui étaient les
semis plantés avec le bouchon leurs racines
n'avaient pas vraiment poussé à l'extérieur du bouchon
après un an ou deux alors que le
des semis naturellement régénérés
poussaient partout et étaient recouverts
de ces champignons
[Musique]
donc si nous si nous creusions ici
euh sous le sol nous devrions  voir une partie de
ce mycélium, il est difficile de voir dans ceux-ci,
vous pouvez voir certains des fils oui
c'est tout le blanc ce
genre blanc opaque regarde bien
c'est le mycélium d'accord mais vous savez dans
une forêt plus sèche ou à haute altitude ça
a l'air en fait  comme une toile d'araignée quand
vous êtes quand c'est sous terre,
vous voyez en fait cette toile épaisse
dans ces forêts plus humides, c'est plus difficile à
voir
mais tout est là,
donc le mycélium le connecteur a une conception telle
que le mycélium recouvre chaque particule de sol
chaque pore est recouvert de mycélium et
ceux  le mycélium travaille en quelque sorte sur ces
particules de sol pour atteindre les nutriments,
puis ils absorbent les nutriments et
les restituent à l'arbre en
échange de la photosynthèse de l'
allée des arbres à
légèrement scientifique.  wow
peut-être que c'est
pourquoi ces arbres ne se portent pas si bien et ces arbres
naturellement régénérés se
portent si bien peut-être que c'est à cause de
leurs systèmes racinaires et après de nombreuses années  des oreilles
plus tard d'étudier cela, je suis assez
confiant que c'était ce que c'était
[Musique]
tu voulais approfondir ta compréhension
de la forêt alors tu es retourné à l'école
à l'université
que voulais-tu comprendre j'ai grandi
ces cette expérience où j'avais du
bouleau à papier  le sapin de Douglas dans ces petites parcelles
et donc j'ai étiqueté avec des isotopes le
bouleau à papier avec un isotope du carbone 14
et le sapin de Douglas était un autre isotope du
carbone 13 en même temps
dans ces sacs en plastique que j'ai injectés
vous savez ces isotopes et ensuite ils l'ont
respiré  dans ou ils l'ont
photosynthétisé dans les
sucres créés, puis ces
sucres isotopiques marqués isotopiquement sont descendus
dans les racines et ils se sont transmis dans
les deux sens entre le bouleau et la fourrure, c'était
absolument fascinant qu'ils se
déplaçaient, ils se déplaçaient d'avant en arrière
et alors j'ai fait ceci  chose où j'ai commencé à
ombrager de plus en plus le sapin douglas et je l'
ai fait parce que les pratiques forestières à
l'époque pensaient que le bouleau était ceci
et ils le font toujours
arbre maléfique ce concurrent qui
volait les fourrures de lumière et donc
vous savez que nous les désherbons activement en
les abattant en les piratant juste en
essayant de se débarrasser d'eux de nos
écosystèmes en tant que concurrent et ce que j'ai
trouvé, c'est que plus il y a de bouleau  fourrure ombragée
ce bouleau maléfique, plus il envoyait
de carbone à l'éperon douglas
et donc ce n'était pas seulement une
chose compétitive, il collaborait en
même temps,
donc vous montrez que les forêts sont des
créatures sociales,
cela montre leurs créatures sociales oui alors
comment l'industrie a-t-elle réagi  à cette
découverte, il y avait une énorme résistance
parce que ce que je disais, c'est que vous devez
garder ces bouleaux dans ces plantations
et c'était vous savez qu'il y avait toute une
industrie mise en place pour se débarrasser d'eux
de nouveaux professeurs
qu'est-ce que c'est à propos de ces arbres ils  câlin
tu
viens et reste ici la
communication
est-ce un autre arbre c'est un autre
arbre
comment savez-vous euh c'est énorme
c'est énorme c'est l'un des plus grands arbres
de la forêt ici
susan simar ade  récemment
elizabeth
[Musique]
nous avons fait plusieurs études qui montrent
que le sapin de Douglas reconnaît ses parents
et leur
envoie plus de carbone soutient de
plus grands réseaux mycorhiziens ils sont plus
nutritifs donc c'est pourquoi nous avons commencé à
appeler ces grands vieux arbres arbres mères
parce que nous avons réalisé  ils
nourrissaient vraiment vraiment maternant la forêt pour
régénérer
ce qui se passe quand les arbres
meurent quand les arbres meurent euh c'est un processus
ce n'est pas comme une mort subite
c'est généralement
un long processus surtout dans ces vieilles
forêts elles deviennent vieilles et plus faibles à
un moment donné et comme  ils meurent,
ils commencent à distribuer leur carbone à
leurs voisins, en particulier aux semis de leurs parents,
afin que cette énergie ne se dissipe pas simplement
dans l'atmosphère, elle soit en
fait dirigée vers la nouvelle
génération d'arbres
[Musique]
alors comment se passe le projet de l'arbre mère
maintenant  avez-vous enfin obtenu la
reconnaissance de la
communauté scientifique que vous recherchiez alors
le projet arbre mère le projet
insert  ect suit un gradient climatique
du nord de la
colombie britannique à la frontière avec les
états-unis et il suit la distribution du sapin douglas,
nous avons environ 25 fours
et dans toutes ces différentes
régions climatiques du chaud et sec au froid et humide
et dans chaque  l'une de ces
régions climatiques que nous avons,
nous comparons différentes façons de sauver les
arbres mères et comparons cela à la
coupe à blanc, alors quelle est la solution
si nous devons garder des grappes au lieu de la
coupe à blanc, c'est que ce que vous êtes exactement
c'est exactement ça alors nous '  Nous avons envisagé de
quitter ces grappes et nous avons constaté
que la régénération est bien meilleure
et donc ce qui se passe réellement, c'est que lorsque
vous supprimez les arbres mères, le
réseau démantèle vraiment les choses, les
connexions vont très loin parce que
ces grands vieux arbres sont
les plus  très connecté, celui-ci
sera connecté à tous les cèdres qui l'
entourent d'accord et si vous enlevez celui-
ci,
ses réseaux avec ces autres
cèdres s'effondreront d'accord
ri  ght ici susanne semar à puberlier
partir
trouver l'arbre mère
voir le bonheur
la raison pour laquelle j'ai écrit ce livre j'avais déjà
publié mes recherches dans vous savez
quelques centaines d'articles de revues déjà
et
personne ne l'écoutait vous savez
j'avais fait ces découvertes incroyables
sur la façon dont les forêts  travail et nous sommes toujours en train
de couper à blanc et d'utiliser des herbicides et les choses
n'ont pas changé, donc je voulais aller vers
les gens et leur dire que vous savez ce que
nous devons décider de nos forêts, nous
devons décider si nous voulons les garder en
bonne santé et ainsi  je voulais écrire ce
livre que tout le monde pourrait lire
[Musique]
tu as été comparée à rachel carson si
tu es devenue une star
hollywood va faire un film sur
toi as-tu déjà pensé que la foresterie
t'apporterait une telle renommée et comment fais-tu  vous
expliquez que ce n'est pas une chance
honnêtement comme les attentes étaient
vraiment faibles
mais euh les forêts étaient ma vie juste comme
c'est tout ce que je savais que je les aime à mort je
et je sais que le monde dépend d'
eux et euh et donc j'ai  juste j'ai juste
persisté et
tu sais malgré tous les revers
tu sais que la forêt m'a toujours guidé pour
faire ce travail
je sais que ça a l'air un peu ringard mais
j'étais toujours là pour prendre
soin de notre forêt et je ne
m'arrêterai pas  jusqu'à ce que je sois mort
[Musique]
toi